all right key & peele man all right you
know we had some bad blood at the end of
the season everything right cuz we got
mad at your started in high res but
you know what we're gonna bury the axe
and I am worried about it no more man
just serious like we're just making this
tape now as an audition see how our good
our writing is we were brainstorming and
whatnot so we just gonna throw some
ideas out too and then also like maybe
do like a little scene and everything
for y'all all right are you gonna do it
what you gonna do I think you said
you're gonna do this with me I know
you're gonna do it just do it alone like
I can't play both characters Eugene I've
seen you do it then when you see me I
mean you done it with me when the
cameras off before this for me are you
doing that man that's stupid
I'm gonna need this I'm oh I'm gonna
need to send a search team down to the
atmosphere yes captain
and when you do that please face down
dick - to the surface of the planet
that's a good idea
bortron did you want to face your dick
down there out that's good man hey Kyle
you some dog you did that man the
cameras on and everything man we
recorded that whole thing turned out
race destiny oh wow man I saw the good
dog erase that man erasing come on
key appeal man you just watched us do a
scene together man
now you all understand man we got talent
and you should hire us man I mean we
have whole lots of a bunch of ideas for
scenes man we got Robo dick we got dick
time machine fart gun that's what we was
reading from 2008 2008 man dick asaurus
rex I am fart legend Johnny Dukey misaki
socks Eddie in the dick cruiser Indiana
Jones a tippler dicks matrix dicks
listen the dik-diks espera wet ex
The Empire Strikes big chinos dick
playing a little forest plan to the
dicks and then we got farts of the dicks
for us to the dicks man we just say we
just keep pumping them out keep pumping
them out it's pretty easy man all you
got to do is take almost any name just
put dick somewhere in there